he spent three weeks Clinging On to his
job at the top of Spanish football but
the pressure took its toll The Fallout
from the Women's World Cup kissing
Scandal was too much to bear for Luis
rubialis about Madison yes I'm going to
do
it yeah I'm going to yes because I
cannot continue my work
[Music]
Spain's first
Victory Saud when rubialis kiss player
Jennifer hermoso on the lips as she
collected a Winner's medal he claimed
the kiss was consensual 33 year old
Hermosa denied it calling his claim part
of a manipulative culture that he'd
created
she said I felt vulnerable and a victim
of an Impulse driven sexist out of place
Act without any consent on my part
the kiss spots protest demanding he
resign FIFA then suspended him and the
Spanish prime minister weighed in
I suppose that within the Federation
there were people who would agree with
his behavior but in the end Society has
changed and that forced him to resign
I'm very happy about it
around 81 Spain players threatened to
stop playing for the national team as
long as rubialis stayed but he held a
defiant press conference hitting out at
what he called false feminists
do you think I need to resign I'm not
going to resign I'm not going to resign
I'm not going to resign I'm not going to
resign
Spain's women's team coach Jorge Wilder
seen applauding that speech was
eventually sacked as the Scandal gained
momentum Regional football bosses also
called for him to go there was a new
Spanish fa president who was close to
rubelles but obviously he was already
making his own decisions he fired the
female team coach Jorge Wilde and he saw
rubial so that things were obviously
moving forward without him and I think
that was the the the Tipping Point for
him to to decide to go
rubialis said he decided to step down
after talking with his family and to
prevent further damage to Spain's joint
bid to host the men's World Cup in 2030
but the Saga is not over yet prosecutors
have filed a complaint with Spain's high
court against rubialis for sexual
assault and coercion a charge that
carries a maximum of four years
imprisonment
Al Jazeera